in case you haven't heard talk to this
respect was banned yesterday one of the
biggest dreamers around was taken off
the air completely but his banning is
part of a wider conversation about
twitch streamers getting banned
something that's been pretty
controversial so we're gonna walk you
through each of those and explain what's
going on here so let's start with the
most recent issue doctor disrespects me
doctor disrespect also known as a guy
beam decided to do some IRL streams from
e3 in Los Angeles this weekend and then
he got banned what happened is that he
and his camera person walked into a
public bathroom in the convention center
which likely breaks Twitch's Terms of
Service which is TOS state that you're
not allowed to stream anything illegal
and according to California law filming
in a public bathroom is an illegal
invasion of privacy no one saw anything
particularly offensive during that part
of the stream other than doctor
disrespects saying he needed to take a
diarrhea which gross but that's not the
point
there were plenty of other people in
that washroom and it didn't matter what
they were doing they had the right to
privacy in their look imagine if you
were just like washing your hands and
doffing disrespect to walked in and
start talking about taking an eye area
you would freak out imagine if your fly
was unzipped and you turned around and
all of a sudden you are in front of
thousands of people it's not great
look either doctor disrespect or his
cameraman should have known that this
was illegal or at the very least
unethical if keemstar
knows you can't be doing this you have
no reason you shouldn't know according
to Kotaku he's also had his III badge
rescinded so there are probably no more
IRL streams coming anytime soon but
before we talk about whether or not
doctor disrespect should be unbanned i
want to compare him to some other recent
twitch bands because this has been
happening a lot in the last few weeks
last month
League of Legends streamer pink ward was
given a 30-day ban
twitch alleges he was participating and
hateful conduct on stream by using a
racial slur he alleges he was just
calling the enemy team Lakers but good
news you can make up your own mind here
pink Ward is vehement that he didn't do
anything wrong that he's not a racist
and that even his chat thinks he didn't
use a slur personally listening to the
clip I agree with him even though I have
literally no idea what Yankers is
supposed to mean his case is also really
similar to TF blades another league
streamer who was banned
in April for pretty much the same reason
twitch says he used a racial slur he
says he just called the enemy team
idiots
he actually successfully appealed his
band going from a 30-day ban to seven
because twitch noted that he didn't have
a history of racist behavior but you
know he didn't still get a week banned
for not using a slur they're damned if
you do and you're damned if you do now
this is a little bit different but I
want to bring it up because it's
relevant at least a little bit recently
twitch users have been getting banned
for using the word Naga in chat Nagas
are pretty standard fantasy monsters
they're snake people they live
underwater and they're in World of
Warcraft and this whole thing started in
WoW
one streamer Saavik said that he shot a
Naga in-game which he did it's just that
unfortunately Naga sounds like the N
word which makes the whole thing sound
really bad out of context now sabich's
wasn't man which is reasonable he was
literally talking about the WoW enemy
there's no way to mistake that but
people started spamming the word in his
and other streamers chats specifically
they were streaming that phrase shoot
some Nagas and a pogchamp nut well they
were clearly being malicious they were
trolling they were using a phrase that
was clearly designed to look and sound
like a racial slur and they got banned I
mean the whole point of doing this was
to get a reaction right talk [ __ ] get
hit look the Naga people deserve to get
banned but TF blade pink ward and plenty
of other people didn't deserve to get
banned for things that they didn't say
so it should definitely be better about
unbanning people who didn't use racial
slurs and didn't do anything wrong when
they get bans but if those people are
gonna get 30 day or even seven-day bans
for not being racist twitch should not
go easy on doctor disrespect
pee poo and others are already calling
on twitch to lift off furnace or sex ban
but what he did is literally illegal not
to mention the fact that there was an
underaged kid in that washroom which
makes an already bad thing even worse
look I
hundred percent do not think that talked
to this effect should be banned forever
it's pretty reasonable to say that he
made a mistake maybe he didn't know he
messed up it was stupid but it was just
a mistake and it doesn't seem like
anybody was directly hurt by it I'm not
gonna sit here and tell you how long I
think he should be banned for because I
don't know personally I hope it's not
one of those 24 hours slap on the wrist
things because again he literally broke
the law and
which kind of have to set an example I
know that doctor disrespect commands a
huge audience and it's probably tempting
to go easy on him because of that so the
fact of the matter is we have evidence
of something gross and illegal happening
and people have had their bans upheld
for far less I also want to say what I
want to say bathroom or washroom and a
camera which one Americans say I think
they say bathroom because my girlfriend
night when we were in New York recently
she asked me for the washer but he just
looked at her give me the background
you're gonna say washroom [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I'm Canadian freedom